doing the advanced trig stuff we've just
been going back over and hopefully as we
were just mentioned this morning as
you're going through these ideas yeah
I'm good it I really get this now far
more familiar with it okay it's clicking
all right at least so we've covered
derivatives of the basic functions the
reciprocal functions the inverse
functions we covered general solution
and auxilary angle so T results okay
now by the way before I get to showing
you this I'm not giving you any more
exercises today because T results is
just an alternative way so look at the
questions you've already got so I think
like actually TV thoughts get mentioned
or they are a viable option for a lot of
the HSC questions I've already given you
so at least in this lesson next time
somebody another question I'm not going
to give you on the street all right I'm
just going to show you this and then you
can use it for other questions ready to
go so where these things come from
do you remember what does it start from
mister what's the basic idea that
underpins all of it yes are we taking
it's not like a half-angle result so we
net10 of anything with beta is usually
the tenth energy T equals 2t okay
so then our mission is how do we get the
regular functions in terms of this and
then you can use it to do all kinds of
algebraic fun okay so if we go ten feet
or 2 to tier theta okay so you're going
to use the double angle result for this
so although this will be you know in
terms of T okay so on the top you have
10 to +10 unit which is T plus T 2 T and
the double angle result for 10 gives you
what
one minus T squared and the way to
remember it is the top is plus the
bottoms - or whatever it's about okay
alright so from there you very triangle
right right angle triangle you put feet
up in a corner okay because it's tan its
opposite over adjacent so you see this
ratio okay
and from there you can say well by
Pythagoras the hypotenuse should be
equal to should be equal to one plus
these men you can um you can check out
the algebra so now that I've got my
triangle I can get all of my ratios not
just hand side will be opposite but on
and cos is adjacent so great now you
know we use these three results you can
use a broad kinds of things I think we
were covering last year we focused on
using four identities because when
you're trying to prove this is equal to
that you start from one side you've got
to go to the other and sometimes you've
got to do you've got to see weird tricks
you've got to add something that's
attracted at the same time or multiple
environment is very confusing maybe when
you read the algebra bless you
it's all it'll just sort of falls out
right and you just have to simplify as
far as you possibly can that's four
identities in the program for this topic
this year
the thing that focused on using this for
is not for proving identities but for
solving equations okay
so let's do an example and I'll show you
how this is just an alternative method
for solving it will do one which you can
do by auxilary Anglos man okay so we'll
do it this way and then we'll do a video
so I think
when I was introducing or reintroducing
was in Rio this is the example we're
going with so let's describe it again
since its affinity huh this is just an
expression but to make an equation that
we want to solve let's let it equal to
say 1 ok so how would we solve this like
I said if we will do this in a minute
you can convert this left-hand side into
an R sine X plus alpha right we will do
that you'll get the same solutions
fingers crossed
okay how do we do it here with the T
results well you're simply going to
bring these guys in
you do have to say let okay because
we're about to bring in T the you know
when T come from and sometimes T will be
equal to different things remember
sometimes you don't use X or 2 sometimes
you can use 2x or 3x or whatever suits
your question right so let's let Han of
excellent to equal to T and now I can
actually substitute all of these results
enough to believe it
so 2 T bear's claws okay so what do you
thinks the best step to go with it to
start someplace
I can consider these two as two T plus
four minus T squared right and I've got
this other denominator which is the same
okay so if I were going to do both those
at the same time by multiplying across
because it's the same denominator right
and I don't like fractions so there you
go multiply across
you've got T square here actually I
might bring over to the right-hand side
and trade keep things positive my ones
they're gonna bigger cancel so they
disappear and then over the right-hand
side I add T squared to both sides and
subtracting okay you can take out your
factor of two and then you can factorize
this as well so you'll actually end up
with this
so from here I remember what T is it's
10 of X or 2 oh sorry I forgot something
of dignity
this is no general solution so let's
apply it domain what would I expect 0 to
PI now the reason why I remember that
this is important now is because this
function we've introduced that we're
solving with respect to T is equal to 0
or 1 so 10 of X on 2 is equal to 0 or 1
domains important right it's important
because it limits the number solutions
you've got but also because this
function is not in terms of X it's in
terms of X 1 2 right that also affects
the domain you're solving with respect
to so up here I'm going to convert this
domain into the one that my function is
speaking in terms on so if I want this
to be an X or two in 7x I've divided
that by 2 so divide everything that you
so the 0 remains unchanged and the to 5
turns into apply so now what I think
about the solutions to these 10 and X 1
2 is equal to 0 and 10 of X 2 is equal
to 1 as you're thinking ok what values
will give me 0 and what values you give
me one this is the domain that you're
restricting yourself with it ok not this
one because it'll give you extra
solutions ok 0
it's 10 look like and where does it get
0 in this domain
the first one is zero because it starts
there right
so excellent 2 equals zero there's one
and then you've got an asymptote and
then it comes back up like that so
there's 0 2 pi so I'm going to mother
solution right there
okay so 0 or pi that's Excel too so we
just multiply through and get our two
solutions from this side of the equation
happy so far 10 of X or 2 is equal to 1
and can you come back to your domain in
your graph within this domain there's
just the one solution and this is an
exact value what value is it platform
good so x1 2 is 4 so you multiply and
there's another solution okay so 1 2 3
so let's just tie it up in same x equals
0 PI on 2 or 2 pi